[Music]
let's go to lindsay in louisville
kentucky hey lindsay what's up
hey john how are you we're we are making
it work today how are you oh
that was heavy that was heavy stuff yeah
so for the listener um
lindsay's been on hold on on the line on
hold and so you you you heard via
telephone that last phone call there um
yeah this is a heavy heavy episode today
so tell us what's going on in your world
well um
man
i just i want to give her a hug and i
want you to tell i want to tell you to
hang up with me and call her back but um
[Music]
man
i my question is um
how i can help my
13 year old daughter who
is navigating through losing a friend to
suicide
[Music]
so what happened yeah what happened
um
this was not
this wasn't a bestie of hers
it was someone that she would had
several classes with
someone that she considered a friend at
school
they were math partners
and
um
he
from what i understand shot himself
okay
and um
he was he actually uh initially lived
and
so he was in icu
um for a couple of days so all the kids
knew that um
so it was almost like
them
reliving it
twice yeah and that i mean held your
daughter
13. oh geez yeah that 13 year old gossip
rumor milled i heard what happened can
you believe just been something fierce
yeah what a mess yeah
okay ultimately he passed away so
what what how has she been at home
she um
it's been it's been about a month since
then so um
we've seen a drastic difference in her
um she went through a really hard week i
mean that first week was just really
really tough um
she kind of has transitioned into this i
want to help everybody
and i want to make sure nobody else is
going through a hard time
and
i don't know maybe that means she's
going to be a therapist one day
um
but i you know i just i still worry
about her sure i mean she sat she just
two days ago sat with a friend
her friend asked her to sit with her in
the counseling office because
she's had some of those same thoughts
and stuff going through her mind yep
and um i can just feel the weight yeah
okay so i'll start it with this
our kids can only be as well as we are
right and so
anytime our 13 year olds i got a 12 year
old in my house anytime our 13 year olds
or 12 year olds or 16 year olds or nine
year olds
are struggling
the first place we parents got to go is
the mirror
and make sure we're okay
what does okay mean that means
you would be pathological you would be
psychotic if you didn't immediately go
what if that was my kid
right um
as mom what did i miss
or i can't believe his mom what do i do
i don't know what i should be doing
should we do something right all those
things
and
for some of us that makes us reach for
one more bowl of ice cream or two more
drinks or we turn the tv up a little bit
more or we stare at our phones a little
bit more
some of some of it is drastic it reminds
us of somebody we lost five years ago 10
years ago 25 years ago right
all that to say is
parents we got to go to the mirror first
and make sure we're modeling what grief
should look like
and i hate shoulds most of the time not
all the time there's some really
important shoulds but this is an
important one
and this is when you know we're watching
natural disasters or war whatever when
we have trauma
kids look to us for how am i supposed to
respond to this
so
here's a couple of things you know this
but i'll just
just to make sure and i've been with
this i've been through this at the high
school level i've been through this
personally i've been through this at the
you know college level and beyond so
there's something incredibly visceral
for a kid when they look over and
there's an empty seat
it's a reminder it's a it's a story that
their bodies are not prepared for
adults have
multiple we we experience more loss
whether directly or peripherally right
we we understand this there's something
when that first 13 year old looks over
in the classroom there's an empty seat
there's a black hole there that is
indescribable they don't have words for
it
um most of us don't have words for it
and i'm gonna get choked up thinking
about some of the students that i've
lost and buried and done their funerals
for them
the second thing that is brutal
that affects all of us that affected the
last caller that affects moms and dads
that affects math partners is this
haunting question what did i miss
which turns into this is my fault
if i'd only seen something if i had only
done something if i only asked something
and
here's the ugly part about that question
is sometimes there's some truth to that
i should have just asked
or i should have said something
often
no there is nothing and you know what i
mean there's nothing out there at any
any any step along the way that's a
that's
a
question that bears no fruit
um i'm i'm haunted by some photos of
students that i've lost that some of the
celebrities that have passed away by
suicide the last few years
you know i'm trying to think of the one
that was the lead singers chester the
lead singer of lincoln park
chester bingfield whose wife posted a
picture and said this is
the face
of somebody um
suffering from suicidal ideation and it
was her husband laughing his head off
playing with his kids like two or three
days before he took his life
before he died by suicide and
so
to think we can guess
is
often impossible if you can see
something in action you get some clear
signs we'll talk about that later on in
the show
yes there's some things you can do in
like the good interventions but for most
of us man it's just our math partner
just our friend we laugh and we go about
our day i had no idea people were
hurting like they were inside um and
then like we mentioned earlier
man
the stories and the rumor mills and the
he was my friend no he's my boyfriend no
i really loved him all that oh my it's
it's catastrophic
it's like uh social media pylons but
it's in real life you know what i mean
is in is that sweet girl just i just
imagine her just getting buried with
this you have her own guilt on top of
there's an empty seat in those classes
on top of
hey did you hear this hey i heard this i
heard his mom hey i heard you would
and for a 13 year old man that's just
i just it's it's
so heavy
so heavy
so you say she had a really rough week
which is to be expected
um
here's my concern for her
her job as a 13 year old is to make sure
she's okay
and i'm i'm worried about her any 13
year olds 15 year olds 18 year olds 25
year olds
trying to
um run from
this guilt
trying to run from this empty chair into
i'm gonna solve everyone else's problems
because it keeps me from having to sit
in the fact that the world is really
hard and that sometimes people we care
about pass away
that's where she needs you
in a real real way
um
tell me about the conversations y'all
have had about
suicide about grief about passing
um we have a pretty open line of
communication with her my um my husband
is military he's lost friends to suicide
and um on the battlefield and
things like that so
he's probably been more of a help and
support to her than anything
my best friend is an lmft
oh fantastic
yes yes good
um she
we i really when i think about the
relationship that i have
with my daughter it's um
i feel like it's really great i feel
like we can talk about really anything
um
she she actually says i have a john
deloney problem because i'm constantly
picking apart conversations that you've
had with callers
and she's like you may have a problem
you should probably go see somebody
lindsay that's not a good problem to
have
so
um she we we have talked about what
death look looks like um she did not
want to go to
um his
they had awake for him she didn't want
to go she didn't want to deal with it
but we
we really encouraged her to go oh thank
you did she ultimately go
she did she did hey you get
you get parenting award of the year
just for that move right there
every parent listening
if your child has somebody in their life
who dies they need to go to the funeral
full stop they need to go even if they
don't want to go if they don't want to
go you go with them
and if you can't go find somebody they
need that that will be something that
reverberates through their body for
years and years and years good for you
lindsay oh so good
thank you
that was hard
that was so hard i mean i literally felt
like i was pushing her out the door
crying yeah absolutely absolutely
she went with a group of friends um her
math teacher was there which was super
helpful and i it was so great
for her to witness
others grief yeah around her it has to
have a witness that's right that's right
and um she she has talked about that um
for
i mean for the past month she's talked
about that
um she's talked about how they've kind
of been a support for each other at
school
she
she's kind of again she's kind of made
it her mission to help others
and she wants to help others
and so i think the the hard part as a
parent is reigning some of that in
meaning
um
she can't take uh
i i've spent my career teaching
faculty members parents administrators
at school
that when a child is in need
that they need to pass that on these are
a professional adults they need to turn
that over to professionals
don't have the tools or equipment or
strengths to carry that to know what to
do next and if you don't know what
you're doing kids can get hurt right
and so the same thing applies here
and i know it's gonna read to your
daughter who's trying
her sweet little brain is trying to
solve for what happened with this will
never happen again on my watch
which means that every one of her
friends that has any sort of i'm having
dark thoughts i'm thinking about these
things
they know lindsay will show up
and lindsay's gonna get tired
you know what i mean
and so
it may mean that
when some when she comes home and says
or let's do this let's do this
preemptively so let me do this in order
here
one thing um i would with all of my
heart you've heard me talk about this in
romantic relationships with you know
with spouses and whatnot boyfriends and
girlfriends i think we should do this
here and i think it will pay you have an
opportunity to give your daughter some
tools that will
uh it's one of these change your family
tree moments okay
um
two things if you haven't already
get and this is one that even if you
can't afford it figure out and overpay
for a really cool nice
mom and daughter dad journal
and have this a dialogue where y'all
writing to one another
okay and
she can right now her 13 year old brain
plus her sadness plus her
the frenetic energy and by the way that
will fade
that energy that's just buzzing buzzing
buzzing buzz and buzzing
um she needs to see it's going to filter
what she hears from you and from your
husband and you'll have some great
experiences that you can pass along to
her that are important that she needs to
hear
and so
um
being able to write that stuff down
having your husband say i was just
thinking about my buddy
dan who died by suicide four years ago
thought about him today broke my heart i
miss him
thank you so much
sweet daughter for being so brave
missing your friend
that kind of letter
will
dramatically shift her healing but it'll
also give her
two firm feet to walk under um so having
some or how is today and her just
writing today was a good day i feel like
i'm doing good things i'm making meaning
of this right that's a way to y'all to
connect that you think you're connecting
when you're talking to teens and often
we're not they know how to play our
games they know how to say what we need
to hear so that we smile and think
they're doing great and they go about
their lives
and so having a dialogue there they will
often write or text things they would
never say in person and so have that
open dialogue and get your husband in on
it too would be great the second thing
is
have you taken her out somewhere and
told her how much you're hurting
no don't hide that from her
i took so here's here's just a life life
example here um the ukraine invasion
happened and there was those videos of
you know parents handing their kids off
and i took my son up um and let him know
this is an important conversation i
closed i closed the guest room door
and sat down and he knew i think he
thought he was in trouble and i said um
tell me what you've been hearing about
what's going on in russia at school and
he told me way more than i thought he
would have known
and i he's asked me some hard questions
and i answer them as as truthfully and
honestly as possible
and then i told him
i was weeping the other day bubba i
started crying
and he said you i said yeah i was crying
really hard actually i'm sad to pull the
car over because i was thinking about
what would happen if i had to hand you
and josephine off to mom
and y'all got in the car and just barely
escaped and i had to stay and protect
our house
and he got really solemn and i said
these are scary moments and i'm i'm i'm
scared and nobody's called me to fight
but here's some things that you and i
are going to do here's some things me
and your mommy are going to do to be in
service to our communities to be healthy
and whole around here
and so i didn't steal for i didn't want
him to think i'm a robot i don't want
him to think he's crazy for being scared
and it sounds counterintuitive that we
need to quote on quote unquote show
strength and perseverance and concrete
you know i'm gonna hide this stuff in
the bedroom um from our kids i'm gonna
cry in my closet no dude invite your
kids into that not hysterics and rage
and anger
but be honest with your kids about how
you're hurting it would be a gift to
your daughter if you take her out on a
special date just you two
and let her know that you couldn't help
but think
what if that was my daughter and
sweetheart if you ever are struggling
please tell me
tell your dad tell somebody at school
tell somebody
i love you
and the thought of losing you scares me
so much it breaks my heart so much and i
want you to know that i love you more
than life itself right i want you to
hold her hands when you're telling her
this stuff
and i want you to know that i i could
hardly breathe when you were talking
i hurt for that guy's mother i hurt that
little boy or for all his friends let
her hear that from you
and she will
her shoulders will drop she'll realize
she's not alone in her house
and your husband can go with you
this isn't a time for lectures this is
how you should feel her grief is her
grief it's going to be different than
y'alls
let her have her feelings and
god help us middle school girls have
feelings
and
middle school boys do too but
man
let her know that you're walking
alongside her in this she's lucky lucky
lucky to have you lindsay thank you so
much for your call
i know there's a whole bunch of parents
out in the country millions of them that
are dealing with the same thing you're
walking through and your daughter's
lucky to have you